buenas tardes será el día de darlo todo
por el todo para que finalmente haya
humo blanco en estas negociaciones que
están estancadas en los tres puntos que
ya mencionas que pueden resumirse en la
soberanía de las partes reino unido está
optimista ha dicho que ha dado un gesto
de buena voluntad retirando las
polémicas cláusulas de irlanda del norte
de la ley del mercado interno que le
permitían le daban el poder de violar la
ley internacional y entonces romper el
acuerdo break sheet hay optimismo pero
también mucho realismo es muy difícil
llegar a un acuerdo pero lo cierto es
que alguna de las partes va a tener que
ceder será una cena la de esta noche en
bruselas boris johnson viajará esta
tarde entonces a la capital belga